Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. For while I have fingers to grasp a sword and eyes to see, your treacherous head is not safe on your shoulders, nor your daughter in her bed. That, Dominic Sandbrook, was Genghis Khan, as played by john wayne you definitely haven't had a stroke no i was i thought that was yet another masterly impression
感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。若想收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。因为只要我手指还握得动宝剑，眼睛还能看得见，你那颗背信弃义的脑袋就休想安稳地长在肩膀上，你的女儿也别想安稳地睡在床上。多米尼克·桑德布鲁克，那可是成吉思汗，由约翰·韦恩饰演。你绝对没中风。不，我……我以为那是又一次精彩绝伦的模仿。
um as i said john wayne uh playing genghis khan the role he was born to play in the 1956 film The Conqueror. Have you seen it? I haven't actually, Tom. I haven't. And after that impersonation, I don't think I ever will. It's basically a Western. That's not how I imagined Genghis Khan sounding at all, let's be frank. No, and I don't really imagine him looking like John Wayne either.
嗯，正如我所说，约翰·韦恩……呃，在1956年的电影《征服者》中饰演成吉思汗，这个角色简直就是为他量身打造的。你看过吗？其实我没看过，汤姆。我没看。而且看了那段模仿之后，我想我这辈子也不会看了。这基本上就是一部西部片。说实话，这根本不是我想象中成吉思汗听起来的样子。不，而且我也真的想象不出他长得像约翰·韦恩。
No, no, that's true. So I don't want you him looking like John Wayne either. No, no, that's true. So I don't know who to blame there, the producers or you. Anyway, so as listeners will probably have guessed, our theme today is Genghis Khan, or is that the correct way to pronounce it? Do you know what we need, Dominic, to advise us on this? I do, but before we bring our expert in, Tom, I will just say this. We in The Rest Is History are not a podcast that does random shout-outs to schools across England.
不，不，确实如此。所以我不想让你……他也长得像约翰·韦恩。不，不，确实如此。所以我不知道该怪谁，是制片人还是你。总之，正如听众们可能已经猜到的那样，我们今天的主题是成吉思汗，或者这才是正确的发音吗？你知道我们需要什么吗，多米尼克，来给我们提供一些建议？我知道，但在我们请出专家之前，汤姆，我只想说一说这个。我们《The Rest Is History》可不是那种会对全英各地学校进行随机喊话的播客。
That is absolutely not our modus operandi. However, if that school happens to be J.R.R. Tolkien's alma mater, and also the alma mater of our producer, Jack Davenport, then we take a very different line, don't we, Tom? We won't make an exception with that. So this is a shout-out to the the pupils at king edwards birmingham tom who it turns out are great fans of the rest is history and are intending to listen to this episode in their classrooms that's wonderful which all children i think nationwide should be doing frankly yes yes
这绝对不是我们的行事风格。然而碰巧的是，如果那所学校恰好是 J.R.R. 托尔金的母校，同时也是我们的制作人杰克·达文波特的母校，那我们的态度就会大不相同，对吧，汤姆？我们不会在这件事上搞特例的。所以，我们要向伯明翰爱德华国王学校的学生们喊话，汤姆，原来他们是《The Rest Is History》的超级粉丝，并打算在他们的课堂上收听这一集。太棒了，坦白讲，我认为全国所有的孩子都应该这样做。对，对。
but i hope also that um maybe there are some I imagine they do drama at King Edward's Birmingham. So maybe that masterly opening will encourage some thespians to tread the boards. And I also have high hopes that this episode will play in schools across Mongolia as people get in touch with their, I don't think they're woke about their history there. So I think they absolutely will embrace the spirit of this podcast. But not just Mongolia, the whole of Eurasia. Well, that's the thing, isn't it? Because that, of course, is our theme, isn't it? It is. Genghis Khan, the greatest conqueror of this podcast. But not just Mongolia, the whole of Eurasia. Well, that's the thing, isn't it? Because that, of course, is our theme, isn't it? It is.
但我同时也希望……嗯，也许有些……我想他们在伯明翰爱德华国王学校有戏剧课。所以也许那个精彩绝伦的开场会鼓励一些戏剧爱好者登台表演。而且我怀有崇高的期望，当人们开始接触他们的——我不认为他们对那里的历史有什么“觉醒”意识——希望这一集能在蒙古各地的学校里播放。所以我认为他们绝对会拥抱这个播客的精神。不仅是蒙古，还有整个欧亚大陆。嗯，就是这样，不是吗？因为这当然就是我们的主题，对吧？是的。成吉思汗，本播客最伟大的征服者。不仅是蒙古，还有整个欧亚大陆。嗯，就是这样，不是吗？因为这当然就是我们的主题，对吧？是的。
Genghis Khan, the greatest conqueror of all time. So we were going to bring in an expert, weren't we? And do you have such a person? I do. And he's very much a friend of the show. In fact, Dominic, he's the only person who has stepped into your shoes when you malingered with COVID. We welcomed to the show, not just just so he'd previously been a guest
成吉思汗，有史以来最伟大的征服者。所以我们本来要请一位专家来，对吧？你有人选吗？有的。而且他可以说是这个节目的老朋友了。事实上，多米尼克，他是唯一一个在你因感染新冠而装病偷懒时顶替你位置的人。我们欢迎节目嘉宾，不仅因为他之前当过嘉宾——
he talked did that brilliant episode on persia then he stepped in to uh co-host with me the top 10 mistresses in history and now he's back it's the one and only professor ali ansari st andrews university ali welcome back it's thank you and it's really it's really good to be back you know central asian warlords I have known. So Ali, Genghis Khan, not the correct pronunciation, right? It isn't. It isn't actually. Well, as far as we can tell, because actually the more accurate pronunciation or rendition seems to be, and I dare say, among Persian historians of the Mongol period, and it's actually Cengiz, it's a C-H rather than a G. So people tend to agree that basically they have the nearest pronunciation. The Persians did?
他讲了那期关于波斯的精彩节目，然后他顶替我……和我一起联手主持了《历史上的前十大情妇》，现在他又回来了，他就是独一无二的阿里·安萨里（Ali Ansari）教授，圣安德鲁斯大学的阿里，欢迎回归。谢谢，能回来真的……真的很好，你知道的，我所了解的中亚军阀。所以，阿里，成吉思汗，这不是正确的发音，对吧？不是的。其实不是。嗯，据我们所知，因为实际上更准确的发音或译法似乎是……我敢说，在蒙古时期的波斯历史学家中间，其实是“Cengiz”，发“C-H”的音而不是“G”。所以人们倾向于认为，基本上他们保留了最接近的发音。波斯人是这样的？
Yes. So you're saying the Persians pronounced it better than the Mongols? Yeah, Persian historians are really the ones that we can't do without. Because a number of Persian historians, and one of them in particular, who I'll be quoting pretty liberally throughout here, was one of the ones who actually went to Karakorum and actually looked at the secret history and was actually invited to write a sort of a... So tell us about the secret history,
是的。所以你是说波斯人比蒙古人发音更标准？是的，波斯历史学家确实是我们不可或缺的。因为许多波斯历史学家，尤其是其中一位，我在接下来的节目中会经常引用他的著作，他是那些实际去过哈喇和林、看过《蒙古秘史》并被邀请去写一部……的人之一。所以给我们讲讲《蒙古秘史》吧，
because we should probably discuss the... I mean... Tom, we're not a PhD. We should have a chapter on sources to start the podcast. So you're going to be citing Persian sources, but the secret... I mean, the secret history is great, isn't it? Because that's... The secret history is sources, but the secret, I mean, the secret history is great, isn't it? Because that's the Mongolian
因为我们可能应该讨论一下……我是说……汤姆，我们又不是在读博士。我们在播客开始前应该先设立一个“资料来源”章节。所以你将引用波斯资料，但是《秘史》……我是说，《秘史》很棒，对吧？因为那是……《秘史》是资料，但是《秘史》，我是说，《秘史》很棒，对吧？因为那是蒙古人的……
The secret history is great, but the only accounts we have, or the only sort of, yeah, the only versions we have left are actually taken from Chinese chronicles. So the Chinese basically translated it, it's in the Chinese chronicles, and then it's been re-translated back. The other sources we have for the secret history are basically
《蒙古秘史》很棒，但我们拥有的唯一记录，或者说唯一的一种……是的，我们仅存的版本其实都是从中国史书中摘录的。所以中国人基本上把它翻译了过去，它被收录在中国史书中，然后又被重新翻译回来。我们关于《秘史》的其他资料基本上是——
a number of Persian historians, particularly this gentleman known as Juvaini, who traveled to Karakorum and actually is claimed to have seen it. So what we can do is compare these two different sources and see what they tell us about the early life of Genghis Khan. And, you know, there's a sort of a, you know, they sort of, they echo each other. So just a couple of things, Ali, before we get started. So first of all, we are in, for those people who don't know, we are in the medieval period. Yes.
一些波斯历史学家，特别是这位被称为朱韦尼（Juvaini）的绅士，他曾前往哈喇和林，据称亲眼见过它。所以我们可以做的是，比较这两种不同的资料来源，看看它们告诉了我们关于成吉思汗早年生活的哪些信息。而且，你知道的，它们有一种……它们彼此呼应。所以，阿里，在我们开始之前先说几点。首先，我们要……对于那些不知道的人来说，我们正处于中世纪。是的。
We kick off in the 12th century, and he dies in the 13th century. That's right. And he is the person who is the architect, the founding father of this kind of huge period of Mongol expansion, I guess. That's right. The most sort of rapid expansion, probably in human history. Now, the second thing I was going to say is, you talked about his his name Genghis but but that's not his original name right no no that's a title it's an honorific yeah it's an honorific and you read various uh you read I mean I I was
我们从12世纪开始讲起，他死于13世纪。没错。他可以说是蒙古帝国这一庞大扩张时期的缔造者、开国之父。没错。这可能是人类历史上最迅速的扩张。现在我要说的第二件事是，你谈到了他的名字“成吉思”，但这不是他的原名，对吧？不，不，那是一个头衔，是一个尊称，对，是一个尊称，你读过各种各样的……我读过——
always taught I have to say and I'm going to stick with this that Genghis Khan actually means lord of all those who dwell in felt tents uh so this is an honorific that he gets in 1206 when he basically brings the mongol confederation the tribes together and begins the uh begins the jolly of you know heading down into what is now china and and just to be clear his surname is not khan so no no not at all again lord that's lord yeah lord and it is one of the great banes yes that a lot of people tend to use khan because khan is also a term that's used in lord and it is one of the great banes yes that a lot of people tend to use khan because khan is also a term that's used in uh persian quite frequently just to mean mister these days it's sort of slightly been diminished uh right over the time uh there's a lot of words
我一直被教导，我必须得说，而且我将坚持这个观点，成吉思汗实际上意思是“住毡帐的所有人的领主”。所以这是他在1206年基本上把蒙古部落联盟、各个部族凝聚在一起，并开始……开始愉快地向如今的中国挺进时获得的尊称。需要明确的是，他的姓氏不是汗，所以……不，不，完全不是。还是那个词，领主，那是领主，对，领主。这也是一大痛点，是的，许多人往往会用“汗”，因为“汗”也是波斯语中经常使用的一个词，如今它只用来指“先生”，随着时间的推移，它的意思已经有点贬值了……没错，有很多词渗透并融入了进来……但在那个时代，它显然意味着“领主”。但他的真名是铁木真（Temujin），“铁木真”就是铁匠。所以他是铁匠，对，对，对。在他成为……在他成为“汗”之前，他就是“铁木真”先生。这是一段……关于他崛起的过程，有趣的是，除了我们所知的内容基本上只来自一个资料来源，而且相当模糊且极具推测性之外……但这并不是一帆风顺的，我的意思是……你看，你会以为《蒙古秘史》总体上充满了赞美之词。它显然会说，他是一个多么了不起的家伙，以及，你知道的，他是如何智胜所有敌人的。但必须承认的是，他成长过程中的日子相当不好过。
that come in and seep in uh but in those days obviously it means lord but his his real name is temujin temujin blacksmith so he's smith yeah yeah yeah before he becomes before he becomes calm he's mr smith yeah it's a fairly i mean the interesting thing about his rise by the way is that uh quite apart from the fact that you know what we know comes from essentially one source and it's pretty vague and it's quite speculative uh but it's not smooth is what the i mean you look at so you would imagine the secret history is on the whole quite eulogistic. It obviously says, you know, what a splendid chap he was and, you know, how he outmaneuvered all his foes. But it has to be said that he had a pretty rough time growing up.
我是说，并非一切都一帆风顺。所以，阿里，在我们聊到成吉思汗本人之前，先说说背景。所以《秘史》说蒙古人是鹿和灰蓝色狼的后代。是的。有一长串的血统传承，在某个时刻，一个神秘发光的人穿过帐篷，他为蒙古人的血脉做出了贡献。但基本上，当铁木真出生在他们当中时，他们只是蒙古草原上一个相当微不足道的部落。嗯，基本上，我是说，蒙古人，是的，有许多不同的部落。
I mean, it wasn't all easy. So Ali, before we come to Genghis Khan himself, just the background. So the secret history says about the Mongols that they are descended from a deer and a blue-gray wolf. Yes. There's a long line of descent that at some point, there's a mysterious glowing man who appears through a tent, and he contributes to the bloodline of the Mongols. But they are basically, when Temüjin is born into them, they're a fairly insignificant tribe on the Mongolian steppes. Well, basically, I mean, the Mongols, yeah, there are a number of different tribes.
我的意思是，基本上在……我们认为是中国帝国外部腹地的地方。现在基本上也就是，我想，蒙古和那些外围地区、西伯利亚，他们……有许多不同的部落，基本上可以被指定为蒙古部落联盟的一部分。我不认为你可以把他们当成单一的人民来看待。有趣的是，铁木真所做的事情，是把他们基本上融合成了一个单一的群体。他并不是第一个这么做的人。在此之前已经出现过各种威胁，而中国则通过行贿或击败等各种方式来对付他们。实际上，铁木真（又名成吉思汗）所做的事情，不仅是把他们凝聚成一个整体——如果我可以这样说的话——而且还确保他们有其他人可以去打仗。我的意思是，
I mean, basically on the, you know, what we consider to be the outer hinterland of the Chinese sort of imperium. What is now basically, I suppose, you know, Mongolia and that sort of outer areas siberia and they uh there are a number of different tribes who who are basically can you know uh designated as a part of a sort of a mongol confederation i don't think you can devise them as one people i mean this is the interesting thing is that what what temujin does is he basically welds them into a single into a single group he's not the first person to do it i mean there have been threats before and the chinese deal with them in various ways, either through bribery or defeats and this sort of thing. What actually Temujin does, aka Genghis Khan, is basically not only wield them into a hole, if I can put it that way, but then ensure they have someone else to fight. I mean,
这就是另一回事了。所以他把他们引导到别处，这让他们保持了统一。在我们开始讲述铁木真的实际生涯之前，先说说背景，所以你刚才说这些部落是游牧民族，他们生活在中国帝国的疆界之外，所以长城基本上就是……是的，历代长城，其实也并非完全如此。他们属于草原。是的。很显然，如果你乘的电梯坏了，你可不会爬上这些草原。它们是巨大的平原。
that's the other thing. So he directs them elsewhere and and that keeps them all unit unified just before we start on his on temujin's actual career sure the context for this so you said that these are tribes who are nomadic they live beyond the bounds of the chinese empire so the great wall is basically yeah you know the various incarnations of the great wall it's not quite quite. And they belong to the steps. Yes. Which are obviously not, you know, things that you go up if the lift's not working. They are huge, great plains.
巨大的平原。广袤的草原。它们某种程度上是草原，对吧？它们基本上从太平洋一直延伸到匈牙利。是的。所以，这是需要理解的关键点，不是吗？从生态学角度来讲，是的。
Great plains. Great grasslands. They're kind of grasslands, aren't they? And they basically, they extend from the Pacific right the way up to Hungary. Yes. So this is the key thing to understand, isn't it? I mean, in ecological terms, yes.
因为基本上……他们是游牧民族，他们骑马，尽管我们也可以讨论一下他们的马的特性，顺便说一句。它们其实不太算……其实更像是小马。但尽管如此，你知道的，他们需要一个特定的环境才能生存。所以那是他们最有效发挥作用的地方。如果你看看后来帝国的扩张，你会发现草原在哪里结束、他们停止扩张在哪里，这之间其实存在着某种轻微的相关性。而且，阿里，历史上有无数这样的例子，不是吗？早在铁木真出生的时候，就已经有过无数次了——阿瓦尔人、匈奴人、
I mean, because basically what the, they're nomads, they're on horseback, although we can discuss also the nature of their horses, by the way. They're not quite, you know, they're more ponies, actually. But nonetheless, you know, they need a particular environment in which to exist. So that is where they're most effective. And if you look at the expansion of the Empire later, there is a sort of a slight correlation, obviously, about where the step ends and where they sort of stop expanding, basically. And, Ali, history is littered with examples, isn't it? Already, by the time that when Temujin is born, there have been tons of, I mean, the Avars, the Huns,
有所有这些人进行过著名的横扫。佩切涅格人。佩切涅格人，节目的老朋友。库曼人……所有这些人都有过横扫。我的意思是，那种轨迹。所以我们总是讲述的关于蒙古人的故事——我不禁把他当作成吉思汗来看待。
there have been all these people who have swept famously. The Pechenegs. The Pechenegs, friends of the show. The Cub have been all these people who have swept. Our friends, the Pechenegs. The Pechenegs, friends of the show. The Cumans, all these kind of characters. They've swept. I mean, that trajectory. So the story that we always tell about the Mongols, and I mean, I can't help thinking of him as Genghis Khan.
没错。他们那种……故事，你知道的，来自东方的风暴，凭空出现，诸如此类。但他们并不是真的凭空出现，因为这以前已经被做过无数次了。关于这一点，我说的对吗？不，不，确实被做过。但我认为，其规模并没有达到这次的程度。这就是区别。
Yeah, sure. The way that they, the stories, you know, the storm from the east, come out of nowhere, all that. But they don't really come out of nowhere because, I mean, this has been done a billion times before. Am I wrong about that? No, no, it has been done. I think it hasn't been done quite on the scale that it's done on this occasion. That's the difference.
当然，有趣的是，中国人或当时正在与中国打交道的各方中国政权——正如我们所知，在这个阶段，中国分裂成了不同的王国。但他们对付这些草原部族有一套特定的行事方式，说实话，相当有效，他们就是用这种方式来对付的。当你审视波斯的腹地时，他们也有对付这些部落腹地的特定方式。不同之处在于，成吉思汗实际上将这个部落联盟转变成了……我认为人们所经历过的最高效的战斗力量。这真是一个震撼，我的意思是，这对体制来说是一个重大冲击，尽管正如我们所将看到的，他在摸索中学习——
And certainly, I mean, the interesting thing is the Chinese or the various, you know, Chinese authorities that were dealing with China, as we know at this stage, is separated into separate kingdoms. But they have a particular modus operandi of dealing with these step tribesmen i mean and it's it's pretty effective to be honest that's the way they deal with it and it's the same when you look at the persian heartlands they have a particular way of dealing with these sort of tribal hinterlands the difference is is that what um jengis han does is effectively transform this tribal confederation into you know you know the most effective fighting force that i think people that people have actually experienced and it is a shock i mean it's a major shock to the system although as we'll see you know he learns on the way i mean
他确实如此，他其实非常有创新精神。好，所以……据说他出生时手里攥着一个血块。是的，这可是《秘史》里的精彩桥段。是的，这表明他……据说他出生时手里攥着一个血块。是的，《秘史》里的精彩桥段。是的，这表明他将继承普遍的统治权。显然。没错。我是这么理解的。我简直不敢相信那是事后编造出来的，
he does he's he's very innovative actually okay so so he is he is born supposedly clutching a blood clot yeah a good bit of secret history yes which demonstrates that he is, he is born supposedly clutching a blood clot. Yeah. Good bit of secret history. Yes. Which demonstrates that he is going to inherit universal rule. Apparently. That's right. I gather. I can't believe that's a post facto invention,
不过是的。所以，他是忽速儿（Yusuge）的儿子。对吗？他曾抓获或杀死了一位名叫铁木真的塔塔尔首领。当你杀死某人、俘虏某人时，你就会接管他们的一切——你拿走他们所有的财产、所有的随身物品、所有的女人、一切，还有他们的名字。所以没错，他长大成人了，
but yes. So, and he's the son of a guy called Yusuge. Is that right? Who is, who's captured a Tartar chief or killed a Tartar chief called Temujin and when you when you kill someone when you capture someone you take over everything so you take all their possessions all their belongings all their women everything and their name so that's right so he grows up
他的父亲是一个相当重要的人物，是一个部落首领什么的。我的意思是，是的，相对而言。我的意思是，我不会说——这取决于你对“重要”的定义。我的意思是，他显然是一个宗族，你知道的，某种宗族……他有手下听从指挥。他身边有人，对，对。他背后有人。但那个世界——打断一下——他所生活的世界，他们住在帐篷里吗？
and his his father is quite a significant figure there's a tribal tribal leader or something. I mean, yeah, relatively. I mean, I wouldn't say – it depends what you mean by significant. I mean, he's obviously a sort of clan, you know, clan sort of – He's got people to order. He's got people around him, yeah, yeah. He's got people at his back. But the sort of world, just to interrupt, the world that he lives in, they live in tents?
对，对。全都是游牧的。他们住在蒙古包（gurr）里。再说一遍，汤姆？我以为那叫“蒙古包”（yurt）。不过不管怎样，是的。对，我以为那是“蒙古包”。他们在爱丁堡
Yeah, yeah. It's all nomadic. They live in a gurr. Again, please, Tom? I thought it was a yurt. But anyway, yes. Yeah, I thought it was a yurt. They have it at the edinburgh
文学节上有一个蒙古包。好吧，我想他们从来没听任何人发过……好吧，他们就是这么说的，他们说“欢迎来到爱丁堡……爱丁堡文学节，快进我们的蒙古包吧”。我想那只是你误解了苏格兰口音。可能吧。不管怎样，听着，他们住在这些帐篷里，到处迁徙，他们是游牧民族。对，对，他们到处迁徙。我的意思是，这确实是游牧。这些不是……这至关重要，尤其是当谈到他们对城市的态度时——我知道我们等会儿会讨论一点他们的生态态度——他们不喜欢城市，他们认为住在城市里的人很颓废，他们看不出那种生活有什么出路……他们不喜欢，他们不喜欢农民、农夫。我的意思是，他们有点……
literary festival they have a girl okay i don't think they've never heard anyone pronounce yeah well that's what they say they say welcome to the edinburgh edinburgh little felton do come into our girl i think that's just you're misinterpreting the scottish accent um probably anyway listen they live in these tents and they move around they're nomadic yeah yeah they move around i mean it is it is no matter these are not and and this is crucial actually when it comes to their attitudes to cities which i know we will be talking a little bit about their ecological attitudes uh they don't like cities and they think people who live in cities are decadent and they don't see where that's going they they don't like they don't like peasants farmers i mean they kind of well they
他们只是……是的，他们唯一真正喜欢的人——有趣的是，你接着说，接着说——是工匠，是那些能为他们实际做点事情的人。所以他们确实会放过这些人。我的意思是，这也是令人瞩目的事情之一。他们会血洗一座城市，但会留下工匠。阿里，我很好奇地得知还有演员。演员？据说如此。
just yeah they they think the only people they do like interestingly as you go on go on, are artisans, people who can actually do something for them. Yeah. So they do save them. I mean, again, that's one of the things that's quite striking. They will slaughter a city, but keep the artisans. And Ali, I was intrigued to learn actors. Actors? Apparently.
有两座叛乱的城市，他们饶了泥瓦匠、木匠和演员。所以你和你的约翰·韦恩……我没事的。我会没事的。我会没事的。我希望学生们……顺便说一句，我应该指出。圣爱德华学校也在学习这个。还有一部更好的电影。
There were two rebel cities and they spared the masons and the carpenters and the actors. So you with your John Wayne. I'd be fine. I'd be fine. I'd be fine. And I hope that the students. By the way, I should point out. St. Edward's are learning this as well. There is a better film.
被蒙古人入侵。还有一部奥马尔·沙里夫演的更好的电影，以防有人在听。好了，我们现在休息一下。等我们回来后，来聊聊铁木真早年的生活。一会儿见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。
Invaded by the Mongols. There is a better film by Omar Sharif, just in case anyone was listening. Okay. We're going to take a quick break now. And then when we're back, let's talk about Temujin, the early years. See you in a sec. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。干杯。一会儿见。购票请访问 theresaentertainment.com，网址是 theresaentertainment.com。欢迎回到《The Rest Is History》，现在，多米尼克，我们讲到铁木真生平的哪个阶段了？铁木真，他长大了。他们有一桩包办婚姻，对吧？我记得孛儿贴（Borte）是他的……孛儿贴在电影里由苏珊·海沃德饰演，别管那部电影了……他……他大概九岁时就被送去跟她成婚，但这是为婚姻做准备，基本上就是在达到青春期时，他们就结婚了。然后他出发了。与此同时，他的父亲被这些人下毒毒死了。他被下毒了——是的，请记住，这全都是《秘史》里的东西。我们完全不知道其中是否有任何真实性，但也没有理由不相信它。
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. Cheers. See you in a sec. tickets head to the rest is entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com welcome back to the rest is history and now dominic where are we up to in the life of temujin temujin he goes up they have an arranged marriage that's right isn't it i think borte is his borte and played by susan hayward in get off the film um he is he is he's what nine years old when he set off to her but he's set up in preparation for the marriage basically right when he reaches puberty then he gets mad and so off he goes and in the meantime his father is poisoned by these poisons he's poisoned yeah again bear in mind this is all secret history stuff. We have no idea whether any of this is true, but there's no reason not to believe it.
话说回来，如果这不是真的，它……它是否可能符合某种程式、某种对人生的预期程式？确实如此。我的意思是，里面确实有一些套路。
And just, if it isn't true, is it, is it conforming possibly to some formula, some expected formula of a kind of life? There is. I mean, there are some tropes there.
我的意思是，我在《秘史》中发现的一点非常有趣，那就是他对母亲总是保持着一种非常崇敬的态度。我的意思是，你……你知道的，你不得不思考一下这个问题。为什么那个征服世界的成吉思汗会如此敬畏他的母亲？
I mean, one of the things I found in the secret history, which is quite interesting, is that he's always got a very reverential attitude to his mother. I mean, and you, you know, you have to sort of think about that. You know, why is the world conquering jengis khan so fearful of his mother
这里面有个套路。我的意思是，就是这种观点，即他基本上……好吧，你知道的，他有个……或者说像泰德·希斯（Ted Heath）一样？是的。所以历史上有一些征服者……是的，他与未来的妻子孛儿贴配对成功。还有他的童年好友札木合（Jamukha）。是的。他成了他的安答（结拜兄弟）。所以这是一个……另一个关键人物。所以这是两个关键人物。
there's a trope i mean it's this idea that he's basically well you know he has a or ted heath yes so there are there are conquerors of history yes so he's been paired up with with with his future wife, Bouté. And also his childhood friend, Jamukha. Yes. Who becomes his blood brother. And so that's a, that's another key figure. So these are two key figures.
然后随着他逐渐长大，基本上就是一连串惹恼他的人。是的。所以多米尼克刚才提到的第一批人是塔塔尔人，他们……他们接待了他的父亲，给他食物，但食物里下了毒，几天后他就死了。成吉思汗回来接替他父亲的位置时，蒙古人却说：“走开，我们不感兴趣。”是的，这很有意思，你认为他们为什么会拒绝他？因为他离开过，而且他……他离开过，他可能太年轻了，不被认为真正能够……挑起大梁。所以，我的意思是，本质上这就是一场权力博弈，不是吗？我的意思是，你必须……我想你得从部落政治的角度来看待它，这种情况相当普遍，你知道的，他并不是一个他们特别熟悉或在乎的人……这就是他们的论点。但当然，这也符合他非常……你知道的，他的奋斗历程、实现命运的挣扎的叙事。我的意思是，你可以看到各种由此改编的小说，但这就是……这确实像一部小说。我的意思是，它真的就像一部小说。这就是神话的原型——如果你想想那个受尽苦难、必须奋发图强的伟大英雄的话。
And then as he gets older, basically it's a succession of peoples who piss him off. Yes. So the first people that Dominic just mentioned are the tatars who um they host his father they give him food but they've poisoned it and he dies several days later and chinggis khan comes back to take over uh from his dad's position and the mongols say go away we're not interested yeah now that's interesting why do you think they would reject him because he's been away and he's he's been away he's probably too young he's not seen as someone who can really sort of carry the can in a sense so i mean you know essentially it's it's a power play isn't it i mean you've got to i suppose look at it in terms of tribal politics which is
他出生时手里攥着那个血块。所以这就是他的命运。他不断地……我不知道，被剥夺继承权，我们可以这么说。但他努力抗争。而且，你知道的，我的意思是，这是一场极其艰难的战斗。我的意思是，在他早期的经历中，有些时期我们根本不知道他身上发生了什么。在《秘史》中大约有一个十年的空白期。我们根本不知道他在哪里。
sort of fairly common that you know he would he's not someone who either they particularly knew or cared for uh um that's the argument but of course it also fits the narrative of his very you know his struggle actually the struggle to achieve his, you know, his destiny. I mean, you can see various novels coming out of that, but that's the, you know. It is like a novel. I mean, it really is like a novel. It's, you know, the archetype of myth. I mean, if you think about the great hero who suffers and has to pull himself up.
好吧，一旦他们拒绝了他，就把他推向了赤贫，不是吗？他不是靠吃坚果和树根之类的维生吗？他靠吃土拨鼠维生，听众们应该记住这一点，因为土拨鼠很可能会在节目后面的部分扮演重要角色。他靠土拨鼠和树根维生……他和同父异母的哥哥别克帖（Bekter）闹翻并将其杀死。所以证据正在累积，这是一个你绝对不想惹的家伙。然后他被俘虏了——我发音准吗？泰赤乌人（Teuchyid）。
He's born with that clot of blood in his hand. So that's his destiny. He's constantly being, you know, I don't know, disinherited, shall we say. But he fights hard. And it is, you know, I mean, it is a hell of a fight. I mean, and there are periods in his early existence where we just absolutely don't know what happens to him. There's a sort of 10-year gap in the secret history. We just don't know where he is.
我会说泰赤乌人。不过无论如何，首领——嗯，蒙古听众请写信告诉我们。我知道，是的。这个部族的首领名叫奇力秃（Kiriltuk）。在蒙古语中，他显然被称为胖子。在蒙古语中。所以他有点胖乎乎的。这个部族的首领名叫奇力秃，在蒙古语中，他显然被称为胖子。在蒙古语中……
Well, once they reject him, they plunge him into poverty, don't they? Doesn't he live on kind of nuts and roots he lives on marmots and that's something that the listeners should bear in mind because marmots may well play a part later in the show he's living on marmots and and roots um he has a bust up with his half elder half brother vector who he kills so the evidence is stacking up this is a guy you don't want to cross. And then he gets captured by, am I pronouncing this right? The Teuchyid.
所以他有点胖乎乎的……他身材非常高大，就是他把铁木真关进了一种便携式的木枷里，所以他变成了一种奴隶。正是在戴着木枷的时候，有我节目开头读的那段精彩片段。哦，原来那就是那个啊！就像约翰·韦恩那样——约翰·韦恩刀枪不入，呀，呀，呀——所以……但他逃掉了，对吧？所以这是一个非常戏剧性的时刻。我的意思是，他早年生活中最引人注目的两件事，第一件事是他的妻子被绑架了，对，所以这是第三批惹恼他的人。所以我们有了塔塔尔人，我们有了泰赤乌人或者无论你他们怎么发音，然后是三个蔑儿乞人（Meerkats）——显然意思是“聪明的人”，但这是不可能的，他们有大量抢妻子的行为。
I would say the Teuchyid. But anyway, the leader- Well, Mongolian listeners, please write in and let us know. I know, yeah. The leader of this people is called Kiriltuk. And he is known as the fat man,
这……是的，好吧，这一切都是为了羞辱，这一切都是为了占有。当然，你知道的，发生的事情之一是，每当你击败一个敌对的宗族——我们称他们为宗族而不是部落——你就会获得一个妻子。所以，你知道，这是那种婚姻联盟的一部分。是的，你建立这个。这是一个血亲联盟。所以他最终拥有了非常多的妻子。
obviously, in Mongolian. In Mongolian. So he's kind of fatty. people is the is called kirill took and he is known as the fat man obviously in mongolian in mongolian uh but uh so he's he's kind of fatty um he's very large and he is the guy who puts um timogen in a kind of portable stocks so he becomes a kind of slave um and it's wearing the stocks that brilliant passage that i read at the top of the show oh was that what that was it was like john wayne that's john wayne impenetrable yeah yeah yeah so um but he escapes doesn't he so that's a kind of dramatic moment i mean the two the two striking things of his early of his early life really are one that his wife gets kidnapped and right and so that's the third people who piss him off yeah yeah so we've had the tatars we've had the tetchy or whatever however you can ask them and then the three meerkats yeah apparently means the wise ones but it's impossible there's been an awful lot of wife stealing with
但别勒古台（Bilka）——抱歉，是孛儿贴——被胖子绑架了。所以他需要盟友。因此他显然求助于他的结拜兄弟札木合。札木合，抱歉，是札木合。但他同时也求助于一个叫脱斡邻（Togrol）的人。多米尼克，你知道脱斡邻被称为什幺吗？瘦子？
them it's yeah yeah well it's all about it's all about humiliation and it's all about, you know, possession. And, of course, you know, one of the things that happens is every time you defeat a rival sort of clan, let's call them clans rather than tribes, you acquire a wife. So, you know, it's part of that marriage alliance. Yeah. So you build that. It's a kinship alliance. So he has an awful lot of, eventually, an awful lot of wives.
不。不，这对 Discord（聊天软件）的成员来说非常令人兴奋。自从戈登将军那一集以来，我们一直管他们叫“王汗”。是的。脱斡邻被称为“王汗”。王汗。所以那是国王首领。我一直觉得你就像个王汗，汤姆。
But Bilka has been kidnapped by the fat man. Yeah. And so he needs allies. So obviously he turns to his brother, Jamuka. Jamuka, sorry, Jamuka. But also he turns to a guy called Togrol. Dominic, do you know what Togrol is known as? The thin man?
这太棒了，不是吗？我想我们就是王汗。不管怎样，对吧。所以札木合、王汗和铁木真把她夺了回来，把孛儿贴夺了回来。基本上到这个时候，铁木真展现出了某种个人魅力。是的，孛儿贴。抱歉，孛儿贴。他展现出了个人魅力。
No. No, this is very exciting for members of the Discord. We've called them wangs ever since the General Gordon episode. Yeah. Togrell was known as the Wang Khan. The Wang Khan. So that's the king leader. I think of you as a Wang Khan, Tom.
他展现出了领导能力。他展现出了杀死敌人、抢夺他们的妻子、夺走他们的马匹的能力。不可避免地，当他们决裂时，他们总是会这么做。札木合实际上击败了铁木真。这就是他处于低谷、可以说是落魄的时期。但有趣的是，札木合——你对此不会感到惊讶——他并没有通过采取……比如把他的70个对手活活煮死这种手段来赢得朋友和影响他人。所以由于活活煮死敌人的70个人，人们开始觉得：嗯，这家伙对我们来说甚至有点太野蛮了。所以这基本上给了铁木真另一个卷土重来的机会，让他得以对抗札木合。我的意思是，这种动态在于，札木合几乎——
That's great, isn't it? I think we're the Wang Khans. Anyway, right. So Jamukha, the Wang Khan and Timurgin get him back, get Burka back. And basically Timurgin by now, he's showing kind of charisma. Yeah, Burta. Sorry, Burta. He's showing charisma.
我的意思是，这非常有趣——几乎是在对铁木真说你有点太软弱了。没错。所以铁木真算是一种中间派。他是自由民主党人。我的意思是，从某种意义上说，铁木真是在说，你必须赢得朋友和影响力，才能建立一个网络。
He's showing an ability to lead. He's showing an ability to kill his enemies, to steal their wives, take their horses. Inevitably, they always do, obviously, when they fall out. Jamukha actually defeats Temujin. And this is the period when he's down and out, so to speak. But Jamukha, interestingly enough, and you won't be surprised by this, doesn't actually win friends and influence people by taking, you know, of his rivals, boiling 70 of them alive, apparently. So by boiling 70 of them alive, people sort of think, oh, this guy's even a bit too savage for us. So that basically gives another opening to Temujin, basically, to come back against Jamukha. I mean, it's that dynamic in the sense that Jamukha is almost,
而札木合则说，这全都是软弱无能的东西。当你击败敌人时，你就该这么干。同样有趣的是，当铁木真和札木合最终决裂，许多人背叛了札木合并转投铁木真麾下时，铁木真并不喜欢这样。我的意思是，他基本上说，你们背叛了自己的领主，我绝不容许任何不忠诚的人在我身边。所以他实际上把这些人也处决了。我的意思是，这非常有趣：他是如何培养出一种非常清晰的忠诚网络意识的。这确实是他的独特之处。我的意思是，与札木合的对比很有趣。阿里，在我们继续推进叙事之前，有一个问题：铁木真曾一度非常穷困，靠吃这些土拨鼠和坚果之类过日子，但他却能拉起一支数千人的军队来击败敌人，这几乎可以说是凭空冒出来的，我觉得这相当奇怪。现在，这是因为他们尊重他的血统，还是因为资料中有什么我们不知道的东西？嗯，我认为……我认为资料里确实有些东西是我们不知道的。
I mean, this is quite interesting, is almost saying to Temujin that you're a bit too soft. Right. So Temujin is the kind of, he's the centrist. He's the liberal Democrat. Yeah. I mean, in a sense, Temujin is saying, you know, you've got to win friends and influence to be able to build a sort of a network.
我的意思是，很显然，他们夸大了他的虚弱，因为这增加了他东山再起的戏剧性叙事。但我认为这也归功于他的血统、他的个人魅力以及他赢得人们忠诚的能力。如果你看看其中的一些记载——尽管当然是后来的记载，甚至是波斯记载——他们大体上认为他拥有政治掌控力。我的意思是，他知道如何赢得人心，他们把他与亚历山大之类的人物相提并论。他们大体上说他是新的……新的亚历山大，新的这样的人物。我们不想过多谈论亚历山大，因为
Jamukha's saying, you know, this is all Nambi Pambi stuff. You know, when you defeat your foes, you do it. And again, it's interesting that when Temujin and Jamukha basically split and a number of people betrayed Jamukha and basically moved to Temujin's side, Temujin doesn't like that. I mean, he basically says, you know, you have betrayed your lord and I'm not having anyone
你知道的，他显然不是我最喜欢的历史人物，但你知道的，你应该读一读……阿里，你应该读一本能改变这一观点的精彩的书……我知道我已经读过了，但是阿里，这难道不也是某种反映吗？——反映了这样一个事实：部落之间潜在地极不稳定、充满争吵，它们会分裂，然后又重新凝聚在一起。所以如果你有……我的意思是，本质上讲，如果你打盹就会输，但同样地，
who's disloyal, you know, with me. So he actually has them executed as well. I mean, it's quite interesting how he develops a very clear sense of, you know, a loyalty network. And that's really quite distinctive about him. I mean, and the contrast with Jamukha is interesting. One question, Ali, before we press on with the narrative so there's there's quite um it's quite odd i would say that temujin has been he's been very poor and he's been living on these marmots and nuts and stuff but he's nevertheless able to raise an army of thousands of men to defeat his enemies you know almost sort of out of nowhere now is that because they respect his bloodline or is it or is there something that we're not being told in the source? Well, I think there's I think there's something we're not being told in the sources.
如果你非常具有个人魅力和手腕，你就有可能从绝对的虚无中崛起。没错，你知道的，如果你开始聚拢周围的一些人，那么呈指数级增长，你就会拥有越来越多的人；如果你能坚持下去，如果你能……绝对的，我的意思是，这有点像电脑游戏，如果你能集齐36个，那你就能拥有你之下的所有部落。好吧，我的意思是，这里的另一个关键因素也是这种“安答”（结拜兄弟）的概念。我的意思是，他所做的是，在此之前，像札木合和其他人非常、非常关注他们各个部族和部落的血缘亲属关系，等等等等。而铁木真实际所做的是，他将不同的群体聚集在一起，创造了结拜兄弟。而且，你知道，他几乎是发明了这些关系，所以人们说他成功的秘诀之一，就是不要花太多时间去考虑血缘忠诚，而是要……是的，我的意思是，他们用“精英统治”这个词，我觉得这有点过誉了，但尽管如此，他根据人们能做什么以及他们的能力来提拔或拉拢他们。当然，这意味着
I mean, obviously, they're playing up his his weakness because it adds to the dramatic narrative of his his reemergence. But I think it's also his bloodline, his charisma and his ability to win the loyalty of people. If you look at some of the accounts, I mean, albeit, of course, the later accounts, even the Persian accounts, they sort of argue that, you know, he has a, he has a political mastery. I mean, he knows how to win people over and they compare him,
自然而然地，如果人们认为站在铁木真这一边，你肯定不会被扔进大锅里煮或是被扔进油锅里去……那这样做就会有一定的吸引力，会有一些好处。然后他就可以把他们的忠诚转移到其他用途上。所以你说的建立这种势头非常正确，而且他通过建立不同的联系来保持这种势头。所以你会发现，在他建立的军事组织中，顺便说一句，也是基于十进制系统的。
you know, with actually with Alexander and people like that. They sort of say he is the new, you know, the new Alexander, the new this. Yeah. We don't want to talk too much about Alexander because,
我的意思是，非常类似于……他基本上创建了新的集团。他把人们聚集在一起——你说的基于十进制系统是什么意思？所以基本上标准的蒙古军事单位是“万人队”（tuman），这也是现代波斯语中非常通行的另一个词，正如我们所说，“tuman”就是一万名士兵。但它从10人、100人、1000人（hazara，阿富汗的哈扎拉人，对吧，哈扎拉人，千户）这样递增。他们被指定在这个……你知道的，他们按这些群体进行编组。而且常常会忽略旧的部落忠诚。你看，他们被聚集在不同的……你明白我的意思吗？我有一个问题。请讲。
you know, obviously he's not a favorite of mine, but you know, it's, you should read, you should read a brilliant book ali that would change i have i want you to know that i have but ali is it not also i mean isn't it also a reflection of the fact that um the tribes are very potentially very vociferous that they split apart yes congeal again and so therefore if you have i mean essentially if you snooze you lose but equally
关于这个。所以……你知道这让我想起我们在节目中讲过的谁吗？不是亚历山大。
there's potential there if you're very charismatic and skillful for you to rise from absolutely nowhere that's right you know if you start to gather a few people around you then exponentially you'll start to get more and more and if you can keep going if you can absolutely i mean it's kind of like a computer game if you can get to 36, then you've got all the tribes underneath you. Well, I mean, the key element here is also this notion of blood brother, by the way. I mean, so what he does, previously, previous sort of like Jamukha and others, focus very, very much on the sort of kinship ties
不，是穆罕默德。所以他把以前一直处于宿怨中的部落忠诚打破，并锻造出了新的东西。他是一位伟大的政治创新者。这是一回事吗？你认为这其中有某种轻微的相似性吗？有，是的。我的意思是，这里面有相似之处。当然，另一件需要记住的事情是，蒙古人远非人们所想的那样——关于他们是纯粹的萨满教徒，还是实际上存在这种伟大的天空神“腾格里”（Tengri）的概念，一直存在着争论。所以这种观念是，他们确实某种程度上拥有某种精神信仰。这并不完全像……我知道人们随后会说蒙古人对待宗教非常宽容。这并不是说他们宽容。他们根本不在乎。我的意思是，这主要是因为他们根本不在乎你信仰谁，只要你按时交税就行。所以这才是真正的区别。但这里面确实有一种……确实有一种精神层面的东西，对吧？不是基督教，你听了可能会高兴。很高兴听到这个，我很高兴我们能把这完全排除在这个播客之外。现在我要说的第二件事是，当穆罕默德和……你知道的，阿拉伯征服发生时，我的意思是，原因之一……
of their various clans and tribes and so on and so forth. What Temujin does actually is he brings different groups together and he creates blood brothers. And, you know, he almost invents relationships so people say that you know the one of the secrets of his success is not to spend too much time thinking about uh kinship you know loyalties it's about yeah I mean they use the term meritocracy I think that's it's a bit much but nonetheless he's promoting people or bringing people towards him on the basis of what they can do and their abilities and of course what that means is that you're
他们的各个氏族、部落等等。铁木真实际所做的是把不同的群体聚集在一起，并结为安达，也就是结拜兄弟。你知道，他几乎是凭空创造了这种关系，所以人们会说，他成功的一个秘诀在于，不要花太多时间去考虑血缘或忠诚之类的东西，而是要——我的意思是，他们用了精英统治这个词，我觉得这有点夸张，但尽管如此，他提拔或吸引人们靠拢的标准是他们的能力和能做成的事，当然，这意味着你
naturally you know if people think that by siding with ten bujin you're certainly not going to be boiled in a vat of water or whatever a vat of oil for you know uh there's an attraction to you know there's some benefit to that and then he can turn their loyalty to other to other uses so he's you're quite right about sort of building that momentum and he keeps that momentum up by building different links. So what you find is also in the military organization that he builds, which is based on a sort of a decimal system, by the way.
自然而然地会想，如果人们觉得站在铁木真这边，肯定不会被扔进水锅里，或者说油锅里——你知道的，这有一种吸引力，对你来说有某种好处，然后他就能把他们的忠诚转移到其他用途上。所以你说得对，关于建立这种势头，他通过建立不同的纽带来保持这种势头。所以你会发现，在他建立的军事组织中，顺便说一下，它是基于一种十进制系统的。
I mean, it's very sort of, he essentially creates new groupings. You know, he brings people together- How do you mean based on a decimal system? So basically the standard standard mongol military unit is the 10 000 the tuman which is another term that is very current in modern persian as we said the tuman is 10 000 soldiers but it goes from 10 to 100 to a thousand hazara the hazaras in afghanistan right the hazaras um the thousand and they're they are designated in
我的意思是，这非常……他本质上创造了新的群体。你知道，他把人们聚在一起——你说的基于十进制系统是什么意思？所以基本上，标准的蒙古军事单位是1万人，即“图曼”（tuman），这也是现代波斯语中非常常用的一个词，正如我们所说，“图曼”就是1万名士兵，但它是从10人到100人，再到1,000人（哈扎拉，阿富汗的哈扎拉人对吧，哈扎拉人嗯，1000人），他们被指定在
this you know they're cataly, they're organised in these groups. And often old tribal loyalties are ignored in this. You see, they're brought together in different, you see what I mean? I have a question. Sure. About that. So that, you know who that reminds me of that we've done in the show? Not Alexander.
你知道的，他们被分类，被组织进这些群体中。而且通常旧的部落忠诚在其中被忽略了。你看，他们被汇聚在不同的群体里，你明白我的意思吗？我有一个问题。当然。关于这个的。所以，这让我想起了我们在节目中聊过的谁？不是亚历山大。
No, it's Mohammed. So he takes people that have previously been feuding tribal loyalties, and he forges something new. He's a great political innovator. Is that the same? Do you think there is a sort of slight parallel there? There have been, yeah. I mean, there is a similarity there. And, of course, the other thing is to bear in mind that the Mongols,
不，是穆罕默德。所以他把以前一直处于世仇中的部落忠诚群体聚集在一起，锻造出了崭新的事物。他是一位伟大的政治革新者。这是一样的吗？你认为这里面有某种程度的相似性吗？有的，是的。我的意思是，确实存在相似之处。当然，另一件需要记住的事情是，蒙古人，
far from being, you know, there is an argument whether they're purely shamanistic or, you know, actually there is this sort of idea of the great sky god Tengri. So it's this notion that they do have some sort of spiritual belief. It's not quite as I mean, I know people then say the Mongols are very liberal when it comes to religions. It's not that they're liberal. They don't care. I mean, that's mainly they don't give a hoot,ot you know who you believe in as long as you pay your taxes so that's the difference really but there is there is a sort of a there is a spiritual element to it right not christian you'll be pleased to know very pleased to hear that i'm glad that we can put that out of this podcast completely now the second thing i was going to say was so when muhammad and you know the the arab conquest happened i mean one reason
远非人们所想的那样——有一种争论说他们纯粹信仰萨满教，或者说，实际上存在着关于伟大长生天腾格里的一种观念。所以这就是他们确实某种程度上拥有精神信仰的概念。这并不完全是——我的意思是，我知道人们随后会说蒙古人对待宗教非常开明。这不是因为他们开明。他们根本不在乎。我的意思是，主要是他们根本不在乎，只要你按时交税，你信谁都行，所以这才是真正的区别。但确实，这里面有一种精神层面的因素，对吧？不是基督教，你会很高兴听到这个的，非常高兴听到这个，我很高兴我们能把这一点从这个播客中彻底排除。现在我要说的第二件事是，当穆罕默德发生——你知道的——阿拉伯征服发生时，我的意思是，原因之一是
the historians say for that is they say well it, it's partly because the neighbors are weak, but it's also because there's been all kinds of kind of technological and political crossover from their neighbors to prepare the ground before that. Is that also happening in the world that young Temujin is growing up? So are they getting lots of new stuff from China or are there lots of contacts that weren't there before? Or is it a kind of unchanging world?
历史学家说，部分原因是邻国很弱，但也是因为在他们之前，邻国之间已经有了各种技术和政治上的交流，为地面做了铺垫。年幼的铁木真成长的世界里也是这样吗？他们从中国得到了很多新东西吗？还是有很多以前没有的联系？这是一个一成不变的世界吗？
Well, I mean, that's an interesting question because actually one of the things that the Mongols are bad at to begin with is siege warfare. So when they start their conquest of China, they're not actually very good at taking cities. It's only after their diversion into the Islamic lands,
嗯，我的意思是，这是一个有趣的问题，因为实际上蒙古人一开始很不擅长攻城战。因此，当他们开始征服中国时，他们其实并不太擅长攻占城市。直到他们转战伊斯兰世界，
the Khwarezm Shaf, what is now in Persia, that they then collect all these artisan and siege workers and then go back to China. I mean, they do sack sentences, but their conquest of China becomes somewhat more systematic once they pick up all this siege capability. So it is interesting that initially they're not very good, you know, at dealing with... Ali, is it not the case? I mean, they have the composite bow, which is an absolutely devastating weapon. I mean, it fires arrows faster and to more lethal effect than, say, the longbow. Yes.
花剌子模沙朝（现在的波斯地区），他们才聚集了所有的工匠和攻城人员，然后回到中国。我的意思是，他们确实洗劫了许多城市，但一旦他们掌握了所有的攻城能力，他们对中国的征服就变得更加系统化了。所以很有趣的是，最初他们并不是很擅长应对……阿里，难道不是吗？我的意思是，他们拥有复合弓，这是一种极具毁灭性的武器。它的射速比长弓更快，杀伤力也更大。是的。
And you can fire it from a horse and they grow up. And that makes them an absolutely lethal force. It's a mobile platform. But there is the argument, isn't there, that Genghis Khan launches his campaigns basically just in the nick of time because it's just before the arrival of gunpowder. Oh, yes. Yes, absolutely. Yes. Yes. You know, a few more decades, they wouldn't have been able to do it because gunpowder would have put paid to them.
而且你可以骑在马背上射击，他们从小就在马背上长大。这使他们成为了一支极具杀伤力的力量，一个移动平台。但有一种观点认为，成吉思汗发动战役恰好是在千钧一发之际，因为这正是在火药传入之前。哦，是的。是的，绝对是。是的。你知道，再过几十年，他们就做不到了，因为火药会彻底消灭他们。
Although, I mean, of course, you know, the composite bow is probably a much more effective weapon than the early musket i mean it's just a question of it's just a question of who can use it to be it to be able to use the composite bow on horseback requires years of training obviously uh which you don't need if you're using the musket so that's absolutely right i mean the the gunpowder empire has really put an end to the nomad you know the but those first muskets as you say ali i mean they're more likely to go off in your face aren't they yeah you know i mean a tiny bit longer than and the mongols use it i mean they do use gun yeah they do they do don't they for show but yeah well they're the first users in europe um i gather anyway so i think i think um let's let's just
不过，当然了，复合弓可能比早期的滑膛枪要有效得多，这只是一个谁能使用它的问题。要在马背上使用复合弓需要多年的训练，显而易见，如果你用滑膛枪就不需要了。所以这完全正确，火药帝国确实给游民画上了句号，但正如你所说，阿里，那些最早的滑膛枪更容易在你的脸前炸膛，不是吗？是的，你知道，比这稍微长一点时间，蒙古人就使用了枪，他们确实用了，对吧，为了炫耀，但无论如何，他们是欧洲的第一批使用者，我想。所以我想，让我们
finish the account of how um temujin becomes chingis khan right so we've been talking about jamuka yeah this blood brother who's turned into his kind of enemy and who boils people alive yeah um they have a final bust up don't they yeah um and the wang khan is also involved in that the wang khan has also turned against temujin he gets defeated by temujin and then jamuka um gets handed over by his own men that's right am i right that temujin basically says because you're my blood brother i will spare you yes yes and jamuka says no kill me well he says there is no there isn't room for two sons in the sky yeah so we're not gonna have this um but again it's interesting that you know the point you make there is again quite interesting and a bit of an insight
讲完铁木真如何成为成吉思汗的故事吧。我们一直在谈论札木合，这个安达后来变成了他的敌人，把活人煮死。他们最后彻底决裂了，对吧？王汗也卷入了其中，王汗也背叛了铁木真，他被铁木真击败，然后札木合被他自己的手下交了出来。我是不是记对了？铁木真基本上说，因为你是我的安达，我会饶你一命。是的，札木合说不，杀了我吧。他说，天无二日，所以我们不能这样，但这很有趣，你刚才说的那一点也相当有趣，并且让我们对
into temujin's charisma in the sense that he that jamuka's own men hand him over i mean it's interesting that, you know, the point you make there is, again, quite interesting and a bit of an insight into Temujin's charisma in the sense that Jamukha's own men hand him over. I mean, it's quite, you know, they decide we know who's on the up here. So again, his political skills, isn't it, rather than just martial prowess? Yes, yes, absolutely. And I mean, I think one of the things we need to get away from is really this notion that the Mongols are purely military achievement. I mean, they're quite politically savvy, actually, in what they do. And so what he says, he he said you're my blood brother i'd much rather sort of be with you and whatever jamuka says absolutely you know there can't be uh two suns in the sky but he says the
铁木真的个人魅力有了一点深入的了解，因为札木合的手下把他交了出来。我的意思是，这很有趣，你知道，你刚才提出的观点也相当有趣，让我们对铁木真的个人魅力有了深入的了解，札木合的手下竟然把他交出来了。我的意思是，他们决定了，我们知道谁现在占上风。所以这再次体现了他的政治手腕，而不仅仅是武力，对吧？是的，是的，绝对是。我的意思是，我们需要摆脱这样一种观念，即蒙古人纯粹是靠军事成就。事实上，他们在所作所为中是非常有政治头脑的。所以他说，他说你是我的安达，我宁愿跟你在一起，无论札木合说什么，绝对地，你知道，天无二日，但他又说
only thing is you know uh you know execute me but i don't shed my blood i mean this is a so it it's again something that's quite common as we said that you don't shed basically royal blood by shedding how do they kill him so they put him on a i think they break his back on the on a wheel i mean it's it's a sort of a wheel thing and they break his back yeah that's not a good way to go and other ways of i mean the other ways that we'll see later if you see us you know obviously in the middle east is one of the famous ones is wrapping the caliph up in the carpet and trampling him to death yeah yeah so it's it's it's to make i mean i'm not sure that means he doesn't bleed by the way but maybe you don't see it it's not okay okay so that 1206 yeah jamukha is is killed he's then declared
唯一的条件是，你知道，处决我，但不要流血。所以这也是一种很常见的做法，正如我们所说，你不能通过流血来伤害皇室血脉。他们是怎么杀他的？他们把他放在一个，我想是在一个车轮上折断了他的脊椎。我的意思是，这是一种类似车轮的东西，他们折断了他的脊椎。那可不是什么好死法。还有其他方式，我的意思是，我们以后在权力的游戏中也会看到，比如在中东，最著名的手段之一就是把哈里发裹在波斯地毯里然后踩死。所以这是为了，我的意思是，我不确定这是否意味着他不流血，也许你看不到。好吧，好吧，所以在1206年，札木合被杀，他随后被宣布为
yeah jengis han lord of all who dwell in felt tents and that's really the pivotal he is now in charge of the mongol confederacy he has this huge military potential uh you know he's politically top dog now what most chinese and other observers say is now's the time when they start fighting each other and it all dissipates but not in this case basically a coiled spring. Exactly. Right. I think we should leave it here for today, but we will be back tomorrow with Ali Ansari and Genghis, Chinggis Khan. We will launch the Mongol conquests and see what Genghis, Chinggis does next.
成吉思汗，所有居住在毡房里的人的主人，这真的是一个转折点。他现在掌管着蒙古部落联盟，他拥有巨大的军事潜力，在政治上稳操胜券。大多数中国和其他观察家都认为，现在是他们开始内讧、一切分崩离析的时候了，但这次并非如此，它就像一根蓄势待发的弹簧。完全正确。好吧，我想我们今天就聊到这里，但我们明天将与阿里·安萨里（Ali Ansari）和成吉思汗（Chinggis Khan）一起回归。我们将开启蒙古的征服之旅，看看成吉思汗接下来会做些什么。
See you tomorrow. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
明天见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家节目、提前解锁、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社群，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。